believe in yourself you have to believe
not only that what you're doing is right
and not only that it's going to work out
but that you have the abilities to
accomplish whatever goal you have for
yourself if you believe you can do it
you can do it and it's never about how
many resources you have it's about how
resourceful you are if you look at any
successful entrepreneur if you look at
how they got started almost all of them
had nothing they're coming from nothing
they didn't have huge investors backing
them from day one they started with
nothing and people told them that it
wouldn't work and they found a way to
make it work that's being an
entrepreneur that's the life you have to
live you got to believe in that I got a
great question from one of my readers
Lizzie who's on YouTube
love you YouTube guys Lizzie wants to
start her own online embroidery store
and she said it's hard to find people
willing to donate or help with materials
I need like sewing machines or ink
presses you have any advice and I love
this question from Lizzie because she
wrote in to say it's hard to find people
willing it's hard to find help not I
can't find help and that subtle change
means everything yeah it's hard but it's
still possible and if you believe that
it's possible then it will happen you
just have to go and do it and even if
you don't know how it's going to make
sense all you see is darkness around you
you have to believe that light is at the
end of the tunnel and keep going and
keep finding another way to answer this
question specifically if you need
resources for your business you need
specific resources change the sewing
machine there's a number of ways to
start I don't want you going out Lizzie
and buying a sewing machine it's not a
good use of your money I don't want you
spending money until you find a way to
make money an easy way to get started
try posting on your Facebook page
I need a sewing machine anybody have a
sewing machine I can borrow see if
anybody has something see if anybody has
a connection make a passionate plea okay
and often the help comes from not the
people who are closest to you but the
people who are in your network
who have a connection somehow say what
you're trying to do so you didn't really
tell me much about your business
I don't feel the passion I don't know
why you're starting this thing I want to
feel that from you if when you're asking
for help you want to make me feel
something when you're asking somebody to
buy something from you
you want to make them feel something
you're not just selling broidered
clothing you're doing something much
bigger share that vision with me make me
feel it then I want to help you then I
want to buy frame then I want to tell
people about you okay so that's your
first step is come up with that
passionate plea post it on Facebook ask
for help
tell people what you need if you still
can't find anybody then I go and try to
find a company who has these things not
the man not that not the sellers not the
guys who are selling sewing machines but
another manufacturer somebody's small
because these machines probably not
being used 24 hours a day and I try to
find the way people to go in and use
their machines either for free at a
really or at a really low cost and again
to make that work you have to have your
passionate plea that the entrepreneur
can buy into you want to talk to the or
that business ideally is a small
business and they get your story they
get what you're trying to do and they
want to help out entrepreneurs like
helping other entrepreneurs if they see
that you're motivated you're willing to
do the hard work that you really believe
in what you're doing they'll wanna help
they'll remember back to when they were
in your position when they were getting
started and nobody believed in them and
nobody gave them a hand-up or any advice
if you can make them feel that then
they'll give you everything you need
maybe it's coming in off hours weekends
whatever it is test it out make sure
you're able to make some money from this
business selling your clothing and if
it's working out if people love your
stuff then you have money to go out and
buy your own machines it's a great
mentality you have here you're starting
small you're building up you're testing
it out you're making sure it works and
then invest back into your company
what's missing is that big picture
vision the passion
that's what's going to help convince
people to follow you to be part of this
to feel like they're doing something
special they're helping somebody out
good luck believe for those of you
watching you like the video please give
it a thumbs up below I also love to hear
what you have to think please leave a
comment anything you want to say about
this video or we have a question for
your own company leave it in the comment
section below and I will make a video
response for you thank you guys we'll
see you soon